Chris in Vancouver you're on the bench
or go for Chris hey Ben I'm uh
I'm a Canadian obviously been as you
said there so I have the benefit of
experiencing socialized medicine in my
life and I gotta say it always strikes
me as particularly nasty when a rich
person like you who belongs to the only
socio-economic group that benefits from
the current system gets on your radio
show and speaks negatively about a
system that would benefit the
marginalized members of the country who
you know by the way are currently dying
regularly from a lack of access to
health care you know I would have some
respect for you I'll be honest if you
just admitted that it was more important
for you to live in a country with a
powerful military than it is to live in
a country where low income people don't
die when they get sick but I suppose my
main question for you is are you big
enough to ride the rides at Disneyland
Chris just a delightful phone call in
every way and while I appreciate the
call let me let me actually answer the
question pretty clearly so first of all
the idea that poor people in the United
States are dying for lack of care is
simply not true in fact there is
Medicaid that is available for a huge
variety of people who are low income in
the United States the idea that we have
a completely privatized system is
nonsense we have Medicare available for
people who are elderly also have
emergency care available for everybody
by law second the idea that life
expectancy in the United States is
dramatically lower than that in Canada
neglects to actually adjust for homicide
and car accident death when you do that
the United States has the longest life
expectancy including in Canada third
people in Canada who actually need
emergency who need any sort of elective
care tend to come to the United States
for that generalized selective care this
is particularly true for cancer
treatment fourth the notion that only
poor people that only rich people in the
United States have health insurance is
absolutely insane 160 million people in
the United States have health insurance
coverage through their employer and the
vast majority of those people by all
polling about 80% of those people are
extremely happy with that health
insurance so the idea that only rich
people in the United States are really
happy with their health care in the
United States is simply a lie through
and through at Thanksgiving dinner do
you sit at the kids table or the adults
table well Chris I tend to sit at the
adults table but then again I have a
functioning prefrontal cortex and I
can't say the same for you I appreciate
listening to call that listening to the
show thanks so much for your
call Chris despite the fact that it
seemed weirdly obsessed with with height
it's a there are there's this group of
people it's really weird it's out there
where people are really obsessed with my
height and it's like um I don't care for
the record I am 5 foot 9 so I am
perfectly average height but if I were 5
foot 4 I wouldn't care because guess
what
I do real well got a hot wife got great
kids got a great life and you're sitting
there calling my show and whining about
the fact that that you're living in
Canada dude so you know enjoy enjoy
Joshua in Florida you're on the bench
bureau struggle for Josh um yes thank
you for taking my call my question is
why aren't Republican States encouraging
Republican counties and Democrats to
take two succeeds for them to join on
the Republican States and what will
happen to the rump states that are left
so Joshua they're they're serious
questions as to whether you can actually
have counties in other states simply
sort of secede and join states that are
next door to be happy
well 2007 a county from Kentucky
succeeded to Tennessee for 1.25 unless
tax rate so I don't actually know how
that worked to be honest with you I I
think that the the notion that this
would happen regularly I believe that
would have to be approved by both states
as far as I'm aware I don't think that a
county is just allowed to leave the
state of California by voting to leave
the state of California but I could be
wrong about that honestly i I don't know
the answer to that my understanding also
is that the federal government is is
involved in declaring a state a state
right the federal government has to
approve the state becoming a state so I
don't know whether the federal
government signed off on that so I would
have to check the process out on that
Josh that's it
happy to say I don't know the answer to
that question so I will check out that
example that you mentioned from Kentucky
and Tennessee but one of the face down
there but yes okay well I really it's
been so long it's been so long yeah well
I'll check it out I appreciate it thanks
thanks so much for the call Joshua
Dillon in Ontario Canada a lot of
Canadian caller stay Dylan how's it
going not bad Ben how are you hey Jim
pretty well how are you well I just want
my original question is about the news
coverage of the coronavirus
but if it's okay I'd like to take a
couple minutes and respond to that
Vancouver caller that she had sure go
for it well my dad has had a lot of
health problems over the years right and
since Canada is you know government's in
control of who gives you medicine and
who can get the medicine he has suffered
over the past thirty years because the
government deems him not worthy of all
that all the surgeries that you should
be getting so I take I take a lot of
problem with what he given you all the
flack because I've seen it firsthand
like my dad has absolutely no say over
his own health in Canada
so that's moodily disgusting that
someone would call in and give you slack
for how your country does things I find
that absolutely appalling and I
apologize on behalf of Canada for that
calling well you definitely don't have
to apologize on behalf of Canada but I
definitely appreciate the sentiment so
yeah I mean obviously I agree with that
analysis of the Canadian health care
system anytime you have a fully
government-run system that that
government-run system is going to have a
certain amount of rationing attached to
it there's what you see with the NHS in
Britain you do have some free-market
options that have cropped up in Canada
in terms of supplemental care that was
finally allowed by the Supreme Court
over in Canada but with that said every
health system has its drawbacks and
upsides the idea that America they're
just poor people dying on the streets
completely ignores how the actual
American health system works it just is
not true in any in any real sense okay
so you want to ask about CNN and
coronavirus yeah so a lot of the
articles I've been seeing have been
painting the picture of absolute
complete bigotry and racism towards
Chinese Americans and Chinese Canadian
now I like living in Canada I hear that
word racist gets thrown around a lot and
I get sick and tired of getting painted
with that brush so my question is what
is your take on CNN running opinion
pieces saying that because people are
maybe staying away from big Chinese
gatherings that they're absolutely
bigoted and racist I mean again I think
that it is perfectly rational to believe
that if you're going to an area where
more people probably traveled from an
area in which an epidemic is taking
place that you're staying away from that
that has nothing to do with race that
has nothing to do with you don't like
the Chinese folks who live in your
area that has to do with risk mitigation
I mean that's that's really really silly
again if you were to you know simply
walk into like nobody's saying this is a
problem with Chinese people this is
people saying there's a problem with an
epidemic that is most present in China
if for example there's a massive
outbreak in Italy which apparently there
is if that if that were to continue and
then there was a gathering of Italian
Americans many of who and recently
traveled to Italy probably the the
attendants would be down I mean are
Japanese people anti-japanese because
they're staying home from school today
it makes no sense it's we saw this
argument by the way right as this thing
was starting there's an argument in The
New York Times saying that was
xenophobic to talk about this virus as a
Chinese virus it's not about it being
Chinese it's about stop eating the
freaking Batman I mean stop eating wild
animals this is now what the third
outbreak that we've seen from China
specifically because people keep eating
animals they should not be eating I mean
it's like that has nothing whatsoever to
do with racism that has to do with stop
eating the bats dude I mean it's just
this is wild stuff yeah in in in human
history the only person that's a de baad
not got sick with Ozzy Osbourne one of
those things where it's just I like boys
say it's welcome to crazy town right
handed I just riding that crazy train it
blows my mind riding riding that crazy
train right there really appreciated
telling let's move on to Sam in
Massachusetts and you're on the bench
bro show go for it Sam Jim brother part
so obviously we Massachusetts you know
Warren how she'd um she's really
declining and she's become a corpus just
like vine has until recently but how do
you think Massachusetts is gonna go for
the Democrats primary well I think that
the the best available scenario for
Warren is that she wins I think the
mitten that again because bernie is
right next door
my guess is that Bernie probably pulls
out Massachusetts by a couple of points
but Warren could easily win
Massachusetts I mean I think that there
there haven't been a lot of polls in
Massachusetts done at this point in fact
I'll check them out right now but I
believe that right now they're running
about even and I would expect that they
end up running about right yeah I mean
the last poll that was done was a UMass
Lowell had a poll that came out we could
go and it had Sanders and Warren
21:20 Sanders to Warren so Buddha
judging Biden and Bloomberg garland
double digits as well so Massachusetts
is a little bit up for grabs but I would
expect that that Bernie probably ends up
winning Massachusetts by a couple of
points but you could easily see more in
winning the state she's not a real
contender for the presidency at this
point she's really running for vice
president as I said during the debate
she was basically slipping her resume to
Bernie Sanders for the VP candidacy so I
think that that's really what she's
going for at this point but you know a
few delegates could help her right if
she gets a couple hundred delegates in
the Super Tuesday contests and then she
can toss those to Bernie to help put him
over the top he could cover the VP slot
for that that's what happens at open
conventions Sam really appreciate the
call Debbie and Mount Carmel Tennessee
you're on the bench Shapiro she'll go
far Debbie yes hi Ben I would like to
know your opinion on if Trump wins the
presidency again will the Democrats
finally let him alone and quit trying to
get him out of office or will it just
get worse nope it'll get worse there is
no better than a being that in the
likelihood is that they probably find
some excuse to trying to impeach him
again a couple of years in I think that
they have to continue showing their base
that they are sufficiently committed to
wild insane leftism and Trump isn't
gonna stop being Trump and the Democrats
aren't gonna stop being the Democrats so
I really don't think that they cool down
at any point I think that they go
crazier especially if Bernie Sanders is
the nominee and Bernie loses I think
they go crazy if Biden is the nominee
and Biden loses I think the Bernie i'ts
go wild on the Bernie i'ts inside the
party I mean the burning aids go wild on
the by tonight's right let's say that
lets say Biden gets the nomination and
Bernie doesn't and let's say that Biden
then goes on and loses the Bernie people
are just going to go after the Biden
people with an axe and for Republicans
that'll be fun to watch but then those
people will take over the party and even
more than they already have and go after
Trump even more Debbie really appreciate
the call
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content